With a full roster of spooky ghosts and a
literal room full of references, Annabelle
Comes Home is stuffed with small details as
opposed to the original Annabelle doll, which
is only stuffed with cotton.
Or whatever old Raggedy Anne dolls were stuffed
with.
Fiberglass?
Maybe that's why everyone's scared to touch
it it's devilishly itchy.
I'm not gonna touch the doll.
I'm not gonna touch it."
Call the babysitter, because we're diving
deep into all the small details in Annabelle
Comes Home, and we're conjuring up plenty
of spoilers along the way.
Right at the beginning, Annabelle Comes Home
puts viewers on familiar ground.
If you didn't notice, the story picks up right
where we first met Annabelle all those years
ago, in 2013's The Conjuring.
That film starts with the porcelain poltergeist
terrorizing some girls in an apartment before
the Warrens step in to take that mean old
doll off their hands.
Annabelle Come Home opens on a continuation
of that scene, which both grounds the story
for longtime fans and gives it a firm chronological
place in the Conjuring universe.
Of course, we also get a little insight into
why the Warrens are so scared of Annabelle,
since the doll decides to bring half a cemetery
back to life to terrorize the couple on the
drive home.
Geez, Annabelle, can't you chill for even
one night?
"Honey, YOKAY?"
The one place you never want to go in the
Warrens' house is into the artifact room.
That door has eighteen locks on it for a reason
there's nothing on the other side but unimaginable
horror.
"Prepare to enter the scary door."
At least, that's true in the film world.
For viewers, the artifact room is undoubtedly
a treasure trove of Easter eggs and references.
There, we can see the music box from the first
Conjuring, right where Ed left it at the end
of the film.
There are also items that haven't shown up
in the Conjuring world, but are taken from
the real world instead.
The book The Black Shuck alludes to a mythical
ghost dog that supposedly roams the English
countryside.
And the Ferryman is a figure in multiple mythologies.
In Greek mythology, he was a dude named Charon
who ferried souls across the River Styx for
a fee.
You like dead people, right?
I got a few dead people you might recognize.
Check this out.
Jackson, Grant, and look who's joining the
party: Benjamin Franklin."
Like a teenage girl with a crush, or a mailman,
Annabelle is a big fan of leaving notes.
"You always leave a note"
Specifically, she leaves notes with the spooky
question "Miss me?" when she's in the throes
of haunting the living daylights out of someone.
This little detail goes all the way back to
the first Conjuring film.
In that intro sequence, the girls find the
message scrawled in red crayon on a crumpled
piece of paper.
In Annabelle Comes Home, the motif shows up
in several different places, notably on the
haunted typewriter in the Warrens' artifact
room.
Also worth mentioning is that the repetition,
and the use of the typewriter, is reminiscent
of Jack Torrance's "All work and no play makes
Jack a dull boy" typewriter breakdown in The
Shining.
That may or may not have been intentional,
but it's a nice nod to a horror classic if
it was.
One of the Easter eggs in Annabelle Comes
Home happens early in the movie, when Mary
Ellen is in the supermarket.
She runs into her friend Daniela, and the
two stop in front of a rack of comic books.
They were only onscreen for a second, but
the specific comics really say a lot.
First of all, they're all DC comics.
No big surprise there the Annabelle films
are owned by Warner Bros., which also owns
the DC extended universe.
You can catch the cover of a Detective Comics
issue, as well as an issue of Strange Adventures,
starring the world's most super-powered archaeologist,
Adam Strange.
"Beware the jub jub bird and shun the froooomiest
bandersnatch.
Got your nose!
Heh heh heh!"
But most fittingly, Annabelle Comes Home director
Gary Dauberman revealed that there's also
a Swamp Thing comic on the rack.
For those who don't know, Dauberman also co-created
the DC series Swamp Thing, which was sadly
canceled before the entire first season could
even finish airing.
Ed Warren was a man of many talents he was
an author, a public speaker, and a ghost chaser,
and on top of it all he was really good at
convincing people to pay him for all these
things.
But fewer people know that he was also essentially
the Bob Ross of haunted houses.
"That building, that building looks as old
as me.
And that's oooold."
Eddy's paintings have shown up in Conjuring
films before.
At least, fictionalized versions have.
The one most fans know about is the painting
of the demon nun in The Conjuring 2.
But Annabelle Comes Home introduces a new
painting in Ed Warren's signature style and
not just any painting, but what looks like
a rendering of the house featured in the previous
film, Annabelle: Creation.
It's not a perfect re-creation, but the placement
of the tree and the remote house are pretty
much unmistakable.
Spooooky!
For those who don't know, the so-called real-life
Annabelle doll doesn't look anything like
the eerie porcelain doll we see in the films.
In fact, the real thing looks downright goofy
it's just a Raggedy Ann doll.
The story behind it is essentially the same,
although no doubt embellished for the silver
screen.
Some girl got the doll, weird stuff started
happening, and the Warrens eventually stepped
in to save the day.
Annabelle Comes Home did pay a little bit
of fan service to the real doll in the form
of a quick clip of a gameshow on the TV.
Don't blink, and you'll see a contestant winning
a classic Raggedy Ann.
It's not unusual for the people behind the
scenes of a film to slip their names into
some text onscreen.
Annabelle Comes Home is no different.
During the scene at Judy's school, Judy inexplicably
stops to stare at the bust of the school's
namesake, Father Michael Thomas Morrissey.
The name doesn't have any connection to the
Conjuring universe or any of the Warrens'
investigations.
But it does bear more than a passing resemblance
to Annabelle Comes Home executive producer
Michelle Morrissey.
Coincidence?
In the Conjuring universe, there are no coincidences
only spin-offs.
Get ready for The Conjuring 8: Busted!, coming
to theaters in 2027.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.